bild und tor öffnen ja die urlaubssaison
auf der griechischen insel kurs in
diesen tagen 170 corona helden sind mit
ihren familien von bild und tui
eingeladen worden vor der offiziellen
eröffnung schon mal auf die urlaubsinsel
zu fliegen für gratis urlaub und wir
waren natürlich im urlaubsflieger dabei
gestern abend um 18 10 landete der
sonderflug x3 4364 auf der insel kos an
bord rund 85 krone helden mit begleitung
die 170 leser haben den gratis urlaub
bei der großen danke aktion von bild und
tui gewannen erst ab ersten juli öffnen
griechenland seine inseln wieder für und
unser spar fords frank boxe ist
sozusagen der reiseleiter in dieser
besonderen reisegruppe frank wie war
denn die stimmung auf dem flug auf die
urlaubsinsel ja die krone helden und
ihre begleitung waren natürlich voller
vorfreude
wir mussten masken tragen dass es halt
vorgeschrieben aber es war natürlich ein
riesen bahnhof als wir hier angekommen
sind wir waren der einzige flieger und
auch der erste flieger wir haben sie
gerade gehört und der tourismusminister
war sogar die parität jahres hat uns in
empfang genommen dazu fernsehteams
wirklich ganz griechenland war quasi
live dabei als wieder gelandet sind es
ist natürlich für griechenland auch eine
wirklich tolle tolle sache jetzt geht's
endlich los
jetzt geht es endlich los wichtig für
griechenland wie stark hängt denn jetzt
die industrie die urlaubs die
tourismusindustrie auf den inseln in
griechenland jetzt von einem guten und
schnellen start ab dieser startet der
jetzt wirklich aufkommen muss jetzt ab
ersten juli werden dann auch wirklich
dann die ersten ferienflieger dann
kommen aber hier war natürlich alles
geschlossen also auch der robinson club
in dem wir jetzt hier sind der hatte zu
und man hat das wirklich gemerkt dass
die mitarbeiter wirklich froh sind
endlich wieder was für gäste tun zu
können es gab wirklich applaus also
wirklich eine eine riesen erleichterung
am ersten juli geht es los und das muss
natürlich einen langsam wieder anlaufen
aber die griechen sind heilfroh dass
jetzt endlich wieder urlaubs
so und unsere krone helden sind richtig
auch froh jetzt urlaub genießen zu
können was machen sie denn als erstes
oder was haben wir als erstes getan
also wir haben es hier wirklich ganz
schön 29 grad wirklich eine brise und
ich gehe mal hier weiter wir haben
nämlich christian weizbauer hier
er ist polizeihauptkommissar und die
erste nacht war schön ja was sehr schön
also bin sehr begeistert vor allem von
der ganzen organisation vor dem ganzen
bild und team ist war alles total im
detail geplant die anreise war schon
riesig spaß gemacht dann gestern die
partie mit den ganzen chor ohne helden
also bin echt begeistert